this is Chris card I'm at cluster fest
at Paddy's Pub I'm by the XCOM people
some hypothetical questions they're
gonna tell me what they would've did and
I'm gonna tell him what I would do this
is what I would've did a woman shits on
the floor of a Tim boys throws it at an
employee that's the Town Hall yeah you
remember this I saw the video I did too
what would you have done if you were
next in line
oh I can't eat there it's like
Caddyshack when they found a turd in the
pool and they had to drain the whole
pool at least got it though I belong I
can't stay here it's the Cheesecake
Factory was delicious enough that I was
like man box minor if I was next to loud
what I woulda did was I would have seen
him throw it and I would have said look
everything I want is on the other side
what I need you to do is grab me stuff
from over in the other register because
if I'm Edison woods I'm really hustling
you don't walk into it Tim boy is unless
you were you on your last leg I think
the important lesson to learn is that if
you throw us her you win the argument
Futurama yes show Michael J fry or
whatever they Philip J fry I'm sorry
we all know the show was really about it
the end of the space Simpsons Philip J
fry
you got frozen and then a crowd eunuch
thing
there you were frozen cryogenically when
you woke up
what cosmetic surgery would you get Wow
well I'd go bigger dong out of the gate
I do that comic surgery I wake up turn
white
I might actually get darker I'm gonna go
with that I want to be true true black
Jesus sue black like like like for real
black you know like black I would like
lights off like really not they're like
just eyeballs and teeth
what cosmetic surgery would you get if
you wake up I get some more height oh
you won't get elongated yes the
phrasings won't do what you do honey
I probably try to dunk off my money so
you just what I would do I don't want to
lose my think and I think it as a
certain Jonas to me so I would just try
to smoke like kind of condense my body
in I want to be like you wanna be
compressed right now fed I want to get
chubby is that a thing Gilligan I don't
want to get smart I want to just get you
this one is about dr. Katz professional
therapist so old Comedy Central show
this show is with animated and a thing
called squiggle vision everything just
looks squiggly in the lines of finger
what would you do if you woke up
squiggly man I'd become a professional
dancer I think I lean into the squiggle
you know I want to look good I want to
be rich I want a squiggle exactly one
good swing
quickly money yeah yeah okay basically
what I would've did was I'm a get away
give it it squiggly dick folks that's
that's really what it's about
that's things Chris Carter that's what I
would do
[Music]